well Turkey has agreed to suspend its
military operations in northern Syria
under the agreement made with top US
officials Ankara will halt fighting for
five days to allow Kurdish LED forces to
withdraw from their positions now that
deal was hammered out in Ankara by the
US vice president Washington said it
would impose more sanctions if Turkey
failed to comply it is unclear if the
Kurds will abide by this deal let's get
the very latest on this now with DW
correspondent Yulia Hahn she's joining
us from the Turkish city of Hashanah
loofa good morning to you Yulia how's
the ceasefire holding up what are you
hearing
well the Turkish government doesn't call
it a ceasefire but a pause of its
military operation because it says these
fires can only be negotiated between
legitimate parties and it doesn't
consider the Kurdish forces there in
Syria legitimate it considers them
terrorists now we're getting fresh
reports of a shelling and gunfire there
in the Syrian town of Russell in which
is one of the main targets of this
Turkish offensive it is unclear at the
moment where these attacks are coming
from the Kurdish forces the SDF for last
night said they would respect this
ceasefire but then again there are not
an official part of this agreement so
it's unclear at the moment if they would
withdraw from the area Washington and
Ankara had talked about the area along
the Turkish Syrian border extending
about 30 kilometers deep into Syrian
territory that's a huge area we are
talking about so it remains to be seen
how things are further developing there
but at least this could mean hopefully a
little break for the civilians there in
northern Syria after more than a week of
deadly fighting okay you mentioned this
a huge 30 deep kilometer area now it's
supposed to be a safe zone that
president air Dewan wants to establish
in northern Syria to resettle some 1.5
million Syrian refugees now in Turkey
what is the cease of opéra the cessation
of operations mean for his strategic
plan to do just that
well it appears Ankara will get what it
wanted there this safe zone is part of
that deal
president Edwin says it's his master
plan to resettle many many refugees not
only here from Turkey but from Europe as
well but there has been a lot of
international criticism when it comes to
this plan and one of the major questions
here is of course about safety that's
the question
bothering many Syrian refugees living
here in Turkey right now these are the
people who might return who might be
returned to such a potential safe zone
now not many people would openly talk to
us about the situation there in Syria
just because they are so scared about
the general security situation there
after more than eight years of war but
we are met some people who are willing
to speak and this is my report in the
distance Amina Muhammad can still see
her homeland just over the horizon the
Syrian city of kobani and jicama
softcore when I see kobani I remember my
childhood my life there all my memories
are over there
five years ago militants of the
so-called Islamic state laid siege to
kobani forcing a meaner and part of her
family to flee to search in Turkey from
here she watches as her homeland fate
once again hangs in the balance the
Kurdish fighters who had driven out to
jihadists and 2015 after months of
fierce fighting are now in the back foot
in Northeast Syria in the wake of
turkeys military offensive and there are
growing concerns that is militants could
regroup badly we've heard that many is
fighters managed to escape and that
scares us we are still afraid of the
Islamists and the fighting we have
family over there and we're worried
about them Annina we talked to many
Syrian refugees here in the border area
and they all told us more or less the
same thing how grateful they are on the
one hand that Turkey has taken them in
and how skeptical they are on the other
hand that the so-called safe zone
president Rajab
Aaron wants to establish in Syria will
really be safe Abdullah Hassan's family
fled to Turkey five years ago from Daris
or in Syria they live in tents and try
to make ends meet with odd jobs
currently they are helping with the
cotton harvest it's not an easy life but
it's still better than living across the
border in the conflict zone says
Abdullah we hear they want to set up a
safe zone to send back Syrians who are
living in Turkey I don't think you will
be safe nobody wants to go back to a
place where they feel scared if it's
safe we'll go
if not we'll stay here Shan loofahs one
of the largest cities here in the border
region with around 2 million inhabitants
every fifth resident is a refugee from
Syria
most of the Turks we speak with support
the military offensive it's important
they say because of the refugees and for
their own safety thank you the operation
is a great thing otherwise terrorists
will turn into a big threat for us and
dragged our country into war give you
remember Allah
it's their homeland and when this area
is cleared and free of terrorists they
can return this Amina Muhammad who fled
kobani with her family is not that
optimistic she would rather stay here in
Turkey it's hard to see a future for her
children she says in the images coming
out of Syria
yo yo you've been out talking to so many
people how's the ceasefire deal of being
perceived in Turkey
well here in Turkey it's now being
perceived as a victory it appears Turkey
has the Turkish government has achieved
most of its military objectives last
night for example the hashtag to kiya
cousin hajeck which means Turkey will
win was trending on Twitter but on the
other side there are of course many
criticisms now towards the Trump
administration many people say now he's
basically given Turkey greenlight to
extend its border into Syria and they
say he's betrayed the Kurdish fighters
there who were the US is the most
important allies in the fight against
the so-called Islamic state he betrayed
them for a second time where they're
winners they're losers and the losers
here as it seems will be the Kurdish led
forces the Kurdish population in the
area the Kurdish led forces will have to
give up a huge piece of territory piece
of land there if everything proceeds
according to what Ankara and Washington
have agreed on yo Johan thanks so much
for bringing us up to date on the latest
on the situation